gorbatchev à bonn une première visite
officielle en terrain conquis
le numéro un soviétique appuyé
officiellement le plan bush pour le
désarmement conventionnel
la répression s'abat sur la chine à
luxembourg les ministres européens des
affaires étrangères blues leur
inquiétude
sans prendre de sanction grâce
présidentielle pour certaines catégories
de prisonniers à l'occasion du 14
juillet des mesures de clémence limité
lui besoin de visa si vous allez en
touristes aux états unis à partir du 1er
juillet paris et washington allège les
formalités pour leurs ressortissants
mais monsieur bonsoir dans un mois
exactement comment sera la folle semaine
du 14 juillet il y aura à paris surtout
les fêtes du bicentenaire le sommet des
sept pays industrialisés est assez
double occasion une trentaine de chefs
d'état et de gouvernement comment
assurer leur sécurité comment déployer
dans la capitale les différentes
cérémonies sans la paralyser et bien les
responsables ont tranché selon la mairie
le centre de paris ne sera pas bloqué
enfin pas complètement plutôt une bonne
nouvelle peau grâce pour la place de la
concorde déjà envahi par les
échafaudages mais dans un mois pour être
ici il faudra deux bonnes jambes
entre le 10 et le 17 juillet circulation
restreinte et pas de stationnement du
tout autour de l'elysée entre la porte
maillot et l'opéra par exemple place de
la madeleine même régime
les 13 et 14 juillet donc vous ne
pourrez pas voir si peu connu mais pour
les riz de reims de la rue royale
notamment il sera possible de stationner
avec fil à condition de ne pas gêner les
cortèges les habitants du viiie
arrondissement seront avertis 48 heures
à l'avancé
vingt mille gardiens de la paix pour
aider les égarés distribution de
dossiers dans les boîtes à lettres et un
numéro de téléphone
des panneaux signalétiques ont déjà été
mises en place pour dénicher les parcs
de stationnement comme celui ci au bois
de boulogne
enfin les transports en commun verront
leurs horaires à rallonge est à signaler
que les services de secours les taxis
livreur avec les sais pas s'ils pourront
circuler suivant le même régime que les
riverains
ces derniers néanmoins craignent pour
leur clientèle ils s'attendent à ce que
ça soit extraordinaire peut être encore
plus que ce qui est prévu et à la plage
ça qu'est ce qu'on fait on fait venir 40
chefs d'état et à cause de ses 40 chefs
d'état on veut tout arrêter
c'est pas du tout ce que nos clients
attendent les embarras de paris n'auront
peut-être pas lieu les autorités de
tutelle et la mairie s'y sont engagés
mais prévoir quand même une bonne paire
de chaussures et donc les commerçants et
les industriels parisiens sont à quai
ils ont écrit au préfet de police
mais demain donc dans une conférence de
presse le ministre de l'intérieur
devrait confirmer ce dispositif minimum
autres grains cependant provoqué par le
bicentenaire les magasins qui se sont
installés dans le nouveau dispositif des
tuileries à paris
eh bien ils n'y trouvent pas leur compte
ils espéraient 10 mille visiteurs par
jour il n'en vient que 2000 elisabeth
est gelée aux tuileries les pigeons ne
serait-il pas seulement des oiseaux les
commerçants sont de plus en plus
persuadés quatre boutiques ont déjà
fermé ici et dans les autres ce n'est
pas l'euphorie on conteste le droit
d'entrer dans le parc qui est de 35
francs
les gens paient que deux attractions ça
se passe très très bien les gens très
content nous aussi mais à l'heure
actuelle des gens paient pour pouvoir
acheter
et c'est ça qui est incompréhensible ce
titre semble pour le moment
à une commémoration pour riches les
visiteurs sont du même avis j'ai repéré
les animations manque de prestige
les organisateurs vont donc créer de
nouveaux spectacles et ils viennent de
l'annoncer à baisser le droit d'entrée
nous allons d'abord séparer clairement
les droits d'entrée des espaces
d'animation vous proposons les théâtres
d'android
l'exposition le film de synthèse et
d'autre part le parc on entrera
désormais pour un prix symbolique de 5
francs la révolution avait permis à tous
et plus seulement aux nobles de se
promener aux tuileries
aujourd'hui certains s'accrochent aux
grilles d'autres ne comprennent pas
pourquoi le parc est à péage par la rue
de rivoli sans doute mais enfin comme
nous sommes un peu fatigués c'est
contrariant simplement courage citoyenne
bientôt que ça ira comme tous les ans
aux alentours du 14 juillet et surtout
en cette année de bicentenaire le
président de la république s'apprête à
signer un décret de grâce collective
accordés à certaines catégories de
prisonniers un dispositif limité et
soigneusement dosé pour atténuer le
risque d'agitation dans les prisons
hervé brusini les premiers détenus
devrait sortir le 26 juin c'est à cette
date que le décret de grâce collective
présidentielle devrait prendre effet
sauf changement de dernière minute
chaque personne condamnée au plus tard
le 25 juin est concerné par cette mesure
son principe dijoux deux mois à passer
derrière les barreaux pour chaque mois
de détention restante à purger cette
réduction ne pourra pas excéder 9 mois
remise de quatre mois en revanche pour
ceux qui n'ont pas encore été incarcéré
exclusion totale de ses grâces à l'égard
de tous condamnés pour faits terroristes
ce dispositif devrait donc se traduire
par un étalement des libérations
de quoi faciliter espère-t-on la
réinsertion pour autant cette période du
bicentenaire avait suscité bien des
rumeurs dans les prisons on y attendait
des années de remise de peine et non
quelques mois entre un monde carcéral
constamment au bord de l'explosion et
les détracteurs toujours actif des
mesures de libération
la marge de manoeuvre
ministère de la justice semble bien
étroite les allemands nos voisins en
sont tout tourneboulé amour transporté
transit mikhaïl gorbatchev est arrivé à
bonn pour une visite officielle de
quatre jours
la première qu'il effectue en république
fédérale et déjà l'opinion publique
allemande est conquise 90 % des
allemands de l'ouest font confiance au
numéro un soviétique contre 58% à
l'américain george bush
les premiers discours au dîner officiel
de ce soir il ya quelques minutes ses
discours comportait bien sûr sur le
désarmement
le chancelier kohl a invité son hôte à
réduire unilatéralement les missiles à
courte portée du pacte de varsovie
dans sa réponse mikhaïl gorbatchev a
plaidé pour des négociations parallèles
tout en soutenant le plan bush de
désarmement conventionnel à bonn
philippe rochot l'amitié bouche
gorbatchev c'est le thème adopté par les
socialistes dans leur campagne
électorale
à l'heure où le numéro un soviétique
arrive à bonn ce pari est fondée sur sa
popularité qui dépasse très nettement
george bush et françois mitterrand dans
les sondages 90 % des allemands à
l'ouest lui font confiance contre 58% au
président américain
première visite en allemagne fédérale
qui intervient donc six mois après celle
du chancelier kohl à moscou à la clé on
ce traité de coopération est l'espoir de
la mise en place du crédit de 10
milliards de francs accordé par les
allemands gorbatchev est le bienvenu
mais sur la route il a pu lire cette
affiche
faites l'amour pas les murs allusion
cinglante au mur de berlin
nous les jeunes nous nous réjouissions
de sa conception de la maison commune
européenne au prince dastan ou non qu'il
ouvre la porte à tous et que tous les
jeunes de l'est et de l'ouest
les français ou les allemands puissent
se rencontrer dans la détente et la
sécurité kafi glace noste vodka
gorbatchev
tous portent ici la marque du numéro un
soviétique il séduit aussi les
générations qui ont vécu la deuxième
guerre mondiale
bersani j'espère qu'on ne va pas le
déboulonner c'est une nouvelle
génération qui arrive et il était temps
que ces vieux schnock soient mis à la
porte
j'espère que ça va bien marcher au
risque parfois changer la lecture des
champions enfin il faut voir aussi les
sondages effectués côté soviétique et
constater que 51% des populations en
urss ne reconnaissent plus les allemands
comme des fauteurs de guerre alors que
30 % sont pour une étroite coopération
avec la manne fédérale
et puis ce détail intéressant de l'autre
côté du rideau de fer en allemagne de
l'est la presse d'aujourd'hui ne dit pas
un mot de la visite de gorbatchev
arrestation délation chasse à l'homme
autocritique
la répression s'abat sur la chine avec
toute la force et les sinistres
tradition de l'appareil communiste à
pékin aujourd'hui d'après la télévision
d'état qui redécouvre la propagande la
plus crue une quarantaine de personnes
ont été arrêtées et demain les
bicyclettes les autobus des voitures
pourront à nouveau rouler place
tiananmen
ils pourront rouler sans s'arrêter la
situation à pékin avec l'un de nos
envoyés spéciaux bruno le dreff et qu'un
vide lors de la répression alors que
l'armée quadrillait droitement la ville
la police procède à de nombreuses
arrestations le plus souvent de nuit
comme pour renforcer leur caractère
dramatique est aujourd'hui pratiquement
impossible à un occidental de rencontrer
un juge doit ou même de lui parler dans
la rue tous les pékinois que j'ai pu
joindre par téléphone depuis deux jours
ont demandé de ne plus les appeler et de
tenter de les voir
pour fuir leur pays avec un seul souci
était possible d'obtenir un visa dans
une ambassade européenne
les leaders étudiants se cache la
plupart en province les médias journaux
radios et surtout télévie lyon invite
sur les arrestations de sotchi sont
généralement traités de
contre-révolutionnaires et de bandits
dans le même temps la télévision
chinoise propose de nombreux reportages
à la gloire de l'armée
la troupe était un des membres du
gouvernement
les soldats y apporte de la nourriture à
la population
l'ami nettoyant les rues de pékin et à
chaque fois c'est même appel à la
délation que l'on entend depuis
maintenant près d'une semaine
vingt ans après la fin de la révolution
culturelle la terreur sa réapparition
line avec cette fois-ci nouvelle arme la
télévision l'image véhiculée par les
télévisions du monde entier avaient avec
force servi la cause des contestataires
chinois et voilà qu'elle se retourne
contre eux ou plutôt qu'on l'a retourné
qu'on la détourne pour mieux punir la
télévision chinoise qui avait intercepté
au moment de leur retransmission par
satellite des reportages des chaînes
américaines et bien la télévision
chinoise s'en sert pour identifier et
pourchassé les manifestants d'hier all
know par l'importance de leurs moyens en
hommes et en matériel des télévisions
américaines ont réalisé pendant
plusieurs semaines une couverture
exceptionnelle des événements de pékin
l'amérique et le monde ont vécu en
direct pour la première fois une
révolution et sa répression dans le sang
jamais dans l'histoire autant d'image
n'avait instantanément franchi les
continents grâce au satellite
mais les télé spectateurs incrédules se
sont demandé pour quelle raison un
gouvernement totalitaire
laissez agir aussi librement la presse
étrangère
la réponse est très simple il fallait y
penser en fait le gouvernement chinois
qui ne possèdent pas de gros moyens
d'identification s'est servi de ces
images pour localiser et réprimer les
fauteurs de troubles
regardez cet homme il a été interviewé
il ya une dizaine de jours par la chaîne
américaine nbc il explique comment les
soldats ont tiré sur la foule massée sur
la place tiananmen
hier l'interview de cet homme a été
diffusé à la télévision chinoise ainsi
que les images de son interrogatoire la
télévision qui je pense en bonne
conscience se pensait contribuant à la
liberté par le bon boulot de journaliste
qui quand même correspond tout à fait à
la déontologie du bon journaliste s'est
tout à coup a été prise au piège
précisément en faisant ce travail de
bons journalistes
on serre
le contre auxerre la répression alors là
vraiment je pense que pour les
journalistes
encore plus que pour le public c'est
dramatique ça posait des problèmes de
conscience très sérieux voici de quelle
façon nous retransmettrons des
témoignages pour que les personnes ne
soient pas inquiétés
en effet sur toutes les télévisions
américaines
les visages sont désormais caché mais la
police chinoise possède des centaines
d'heures d'enregistrement lui permettant
de mener à bien la normalisation du pays
la télévision chinoise annonce ce soir
que le mandat d'arrêt lancé contre fans
l'isi l'astrophysicien dissidents et son
épouse tous deux réfugiés depuis sept
jours à l'ambassade américaine à pékin
ce mandat d'arrêt désormais affichée
dans toute la chine
washington vient de répéter qu'il n'est
pas question de rendre le liant aux
autorités à hong kong où l'inquiétude
reste à vif des centaines de ballons oui
des ballons auxquels étaient attachés
des coupures de journaux ont été lâchés
dans l'espoir que le vent les portes
vers le continent et que les chinois
restent ainsi informés de la situation
a luxembourg où étaient réunies
aujourd'hui les ministres de l'est des
affaires étrangères de la communauté
pas de déclaration officielle commune
sur la chine
pas de sanction non plus décidé en
commun mais l'espagne qui préside
actuellement la communauté elle va
entreprendre à pékin une démarche
diplomatique au nom des douze pour
exprimer leur réprobation
une chose est sûre en tout cas il n'y
aura pas de délégation chinoise aux
fêtes du bicentenaire une délégation de
200 artistes chinois devait participer
au défilé spectacle du 14 juillet ils ne
viendront pas ils seront remplacés par
des étudiants chinois de paris annoncé
tout à l'heure le ministère de la
culture
la france va renvoyer son ambassadeur en
iran il avait été rappelé en
consultations comme on dit au moment de
la faire rudi roland dumas qui a annoncé
la nouvelle tout à l'heure à luxembourg
l'expliquent par le nouveau contexte
politique qui règne dit-il à téhéran à
téhéran le président du parlement
rafsanjani a été réélu aujourd'hui
reconduit dans ses fonctions il a déjà
annoncé sa candidature à l'élection
présidentielle qui aura lieu en ou la
disparition de l'ayatollah khomeini
continue de mettre en transe ses fidèles
hier à l'occasion du 7ème jour de sa
mort une immense manifestation a déferlé
sur le sud de téhéran
au coeur de cette foule patricia cost et
franck brice est bloquée bloqué pour la
deuxième fois consécutive dans un des
plus gigantesques embouteillages jamais
vu la chaleur monte 40 à 45 degrés dans
le désert qui commence aux portes de
téhéran le nombre croît ils sont venus
encore une fois par millions plutôt de
province dont par autobus qu'ils seront
obligés d'abandonner à plusieurs
kilomètres du but
l'expression de la douleur s'amplifie
kas est soudain par une course pour des
fruits que l'on distribue gratuitement
spectacle hallucinant à 15 km de téhéran
en ce dimanche après midi qui marque le
septième jour du deuil de l'imam commune
s'extraire seul un hélicoptère pourra
nous aider à le faire pour rejoindre le
lieu de la cérémonie qui a déjà commencé
la foule chiite en noir vu du ciel prend
des allures de phénomène a tiré comme
par un pôle magnétique les colonnes noir
se dirige vers la coupole dorée tout
juste posé dans la nuit sont les
containers qui recouvre le corps de
l'imam
deux heures plus tard la cérémonie est
terminée
les mercedes quitte par un cordon de
béton l'enceinte sacrée les hauts
dignitaires chiites s'en vont la tombe
de l'imam khomeiny et laissait alors à
la multitude ou praticable haut parleur
aux hélicoptères qui déversent de l'eau
de rose sur la foule aux couronnes de
fleurs que l'on s'arrange au grand
désordre
un délire en fait bien contrôlé s'est
installée comme la seconde nature
dernière image celle de l'imam khomeiny
enfin souriant sur les posters va-t-on
vers une amnistie totale y compris les
crimes de sang en nouvelle calédonie le
rpr dit déjà son hostilité à une telle
mesure que le premier ministre michel
rocard évoquait la nuit dernière sur rfo
en se félicitant des résultats des
élections provinciales dans le
territoire laurent boussier qu'il ya à
peine plus d'un mois lorsque j'envoie
utile
ils ont été assassinés qu'on verrait
nouvelle calédonie voté à près de 70% et
sans un incident dans le calme le plus
absolu c'est déjà un très bon résultat
et puis ce résultat se confirme dans
l'expression même du vote de nouvelle
calédonie puisque 85 % des sièges ou sur
l'ensemble du territoire dans les trois
provinces et par conséquent au congrès
du territoire seront tenus par des
formations signataires des accords
matignon des élections conformes aux
espoirs des artisans des accords de
matignon le territoire compte maintenant
trois régions avec un grand vainqueur
dans le sud la région la plus peuplée le
rpcr pour jacques lafleur cette élection
doit ouvrir une nouvelle impulsion
politique
nous allons donner une impulsion de
politique en nouvelle calédonie vers une
consolidation de la paix un
développement d'économie une politique
de rattrapage et de justice c'est cette
nous allons proposer grands vainqueurs
dans le nord et sur les îles loyauté le
fln ks mais pour françois burck cette
élection n'est qu'une étape
les provinciales qui se met au travail
se met au travail ou en 98
mais mis sur pied une indépendance
indépendantiste anti-indépendantistes
aujourd'hui presque tous acceptent le
nouveau statut de la nouvelle calédonie
c'était surtout ça le souhait du
gouvernement
la campagne pour les européennes
à cinq jours du scrutin c'est le moment
de faire le point sur le style l'allant
la tactique des unes et des autres têtes
de liste
ce soir laurent fabius vu par rachid
arhab organiser un déplacement électoral
dans le midi socialiste cela tient du
miracle ou du parcours du combattant
laurent fabius avait aujourd'hui un
programme simple n'oublier personne sur
l'échiquier politique méridionale
première étape de la région alès alès où
la mairie a été récemment perdu par les
communistes
deuxième étape arles où le socialiste
michel vauzelle ancien porte-parole de
l'elysée a raté de peu la municipalité
en mars dernier troisième étape à aix en
provence où le
si socialistes a profité de la division
de la droite pour conquérir l'hôtel de
ville une campagne systématique donc
comme sont systématiques les thèses
abordé par laurent fabius
par exemple le président de l'assemblée
nationale tu prends un fort l'abstention
ne cesse de répéter qu'il se place dans
le sillage de françois mitterrand ici
dans les bouches du rhône comme partout
en france on a besoin de rassemblement
moi je me souviens très bien que quand
le président mitterrand m'a nommé
premier ministre
je vais demander qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire président et après une fois qu'il
m'a répondu j'ai dit mon action ce sera
modernisée et grâce à cette volonté de
rassemblement elle ne m'a pas quittée
elle doit s'appliquer ici parce que le
rassemblement est la clé du succès à
marseille pour ne pas faire de jaloux
laurent fabius a d'abord rendu visite à
robert vigouroux le maire exclu du ps
avant d'aller voir michel peser le
candidat socialiste malheureux
bref laurent fabius ne néglige rien en
cette fin de campagne
il s'adapte au terrain prenant même
l'accent quand il le faut les élections
européennes ont lieu aussi chez nos
partenaires connaîtrait-il le
déchaînement des passions l'entousiasme
sur les grands enjeux
commençons notre tour d'europe parme
italie avec marcel trillât comment faire
pour passionner les italiens à la
campagne des européennes
sachant que tous les partis politiques
sans aucune exception sont de fervents
européen dur dur
dans un pays où la polémique politique
fait figure de sport national juste
après le football cela risquait de
manquer singulièrement de sel deux
ténors de la politique italienne le
socialiste bettino craxi ancien premier
ministre et le démocrate-chrétien
thiriat co2 mita premier ministre depuis
un an ce sont donc dévoué pour trouver
une issue à cette impasse
ils ont provoqué il ya quinze jours la
48e crise gouvernementale en 44 ans un
record but de l'opération utiliser les
européennes comme un vaste sondage
mais tant de départager les frères
ennemis de la coalition au pouvoir
socialistes démocrates chrétiens
libéraux républicains et sociaux
démocrates après le 18 juin
on comptera les points et en modifiera
en conséquence les savants dosages de
l'alliance gouvernementale
en attendant les électeurs tente de s'y
retrouver dans l'imbroglio inextricable
des européennes à l'italienne
le pays est en effet divisé en cinq
circonscriptions dans chacune d'entre
elles douze à quatorze liste mais de
nombreux ténors se présente en même
temps dans plusieurs circonscriptions
autre invention italienne pour
compliquer un peu plus les règles du jeu
une loi récente permet à chacun des
partis de présenter des candidats
étrangers
le français maurice duverger par exemple
numéro 2 sur une liste communiste
juste après le nouveau secrétaire
général à qu'il est ok tôt dernière
trouvaille enfin les italiens devront
aussi répondre le 18 juin un référendum
est tous d'accord
oui ou non pour renforcer les pouvoirs
du parlement européen ce qui lui
permettrait par exemple intérieurement
d'élire directement un gouvernement
supranational
mais l'immense majorité des italiens
n'ont encore jamais entendu parler d'eux
sur la farandole laissons leur la
surprise violents affrontements
aujourd'hui en belgique dans le limbourg
entre mineurs et gendarmes
anne ponsinet
quinze blessés dont six gendarmes ce
matin au cours d'affrontements entre
mineurs et forces de l'ordre dans la
province du limbourg en belgique et 3000
mineurs qui voulaient marcher sur la
ville d'hasselt ont résisté à trois
charges à cheval ils protestent contre
la fermeture anticipée en 1992 les deux
dernières mines belge
une délégation a été reçue cet après
midi par le premier ministre wilfried
martens
troisième jour d'occupation de la
centrale de golfech par quatre militants
antinucléaires
perché sur une des tours de
refroidissement il exige l'organisation
d'un débat télévisé sur la poursuite de
l'utilisation du nucléaire en france
faute de quoi ils menacent d'entamer une
grève de la faim
1988 meilleure année depuis dix ans pour
l'industrie française selon un rapport
de l'insee publiée aujourd'hui +4 9%
pour la production industrielle un
chiffre qui ne dépasse cependant pas la
moyenne européenne qui reste des points
noirs le manque de compétitivité et
l'emploi continue de se détériorer
même si cette dégradation fait ralenti
forte hausse du dollar aujourd'hui à
paris 6 87 au fixing contre 74 vendredi
et au milieu de matinée le billet vert a
atteint son plus haut niveau depuis deux
ans l'explication vient peut-être des
marchés asiatiques qui délaisse le yale
pour le dollar devise encore la peseta
espagnole et l'escudo portugais
entreront en septembre prochain dans la
composition de l'unité de compte
européennes les pus un pas de plus vers
le système monétaire européen
deux confirmations intéressant à la tête
d'entreprises nationaliser celle de jean
rené fourtou le président de rhône
poulenc et celle de jean-paul escande
reconduit à la tête de la société
marseillaise de crédit plus de visa pour
les etats unis à partir du 1er juillet
en tout cas pour les touristes français
paris et washington allège les
formalités michelle perrot jusqu'à
présent pour tout premier séjour aux
états unis un rituel initiatique était
indispensable une bonne page d'écriture
d'abord avec un questionnaire serré et
parfois un discret et puis deux à trois
heures d'attentes afin d'obtenir
l'empreinte qui vous ouvrez enfin et
portes du nouveau monde
désormais il suffira de remplir ce
formulaire que vous remettrez avec votre
passeport au contrôle d'immigration de
l'aéroport américain
une disposition uniquement valable pour
les séjours de touristes ou d'affaires
ne dépassant pas trois mois
simultanément la france via de supprimer
l'exigence de visas rétabli pour les
américains après les attentats de paris
en 86 nous sommes donc le troisième pays
avec lequel les etats-unis ont signé un
tel accord de réciprocité
ce sont les pays les plus importants
pour le toulousain les états unis par
exemple
le japon la grande bretagne et la france
sont les pays les trois pays les plus
importants mais avec ou sans visa
l'officier d'immigration pourra toujours
refusé l'entrée du territoire américain
à certaines personnes notamment celles
ayant eu des antécédents criminels
atteintes de maladies contagieuses ou
membres de certaines organisations comme
le parti communiste
ils ont fait et élever ensemble 16
enfants 16 ses nuits juni à charge qui
sera consacrée demain au sénat
le père le plus méritant de france
pascal deschamps nous raconte son
histoire
julien charme et sa femme gilberte n'en
reviennent pas leurs seize enfants et 25
petits-enfants pas moins leur avait fait
la surprise de les accompagner à la
mairie du village où ils viennent de
prendre le car pour paris pour y être
dignement récompense est impressionnante
photo de famille maintenant c est
maintenant qu en matière plaisir c'est
d'avoir deux grammes peut se passer je
vois pas quoi dire
non non j'en étais comme sans peine 1
100 malades lycéens puis on a la joie de
les a poussés à boire la tasse pâtissons
gens savent rire de tout cas deschamps
petit seriez de plus en plus d'un
certain âge d'être pénible 10 entre 12
et 16 heures 17 heures d'estimations
si le plus dur est fait il ne faudrait
pas croire pour autant que la vie d'une
famille méritante et facile tous les
jours avec un salaire de 8000 francs par
mois
pas question de partir en vacances ni
d'avoir seize chambres chacun la sienne
pourtant aucun de leurs rejetons en vie
aujourd'hui l'existence de l'enfant
unique avait fait d'avoir tort
d'ailleurs au bel effet
d'habitude quand ça s'est passé c'est
bien on s'entend bien la dernière
pas du tout même après tout pour julien
charrault ce n'est que justice sa digne
et poules n'avait-elle pas reçu d leur
dixième enfant il ya 39 ans la médaille
d'or de la famille française pour sa
collaboration il méritait bien lui aussi
une petite récompense c'est chose faite
et va revoir tous les deux ben johnson
sur le banc des accusés l'athlète
canadien qui avait gagné à séoul avant
d'être disqualifié pour dopage p johnson
comparaissait aujourd'hui dans son
propre procès au tribunal de toronto
chamba maire la médaille de la honte n'a
pas fini de faire couler de l'encré
la course de la honte reste encore
présente dans toutes les mémoires
et depuis l'enquêté la société a fait se
régler quelques comptes qui ne font pas
toujours honneur au sport ni à la morale
le puise aujourd'hui ben johnson et
l'invité à son propre procès et si comme
le veut la loi
il a juré de ne dire que la vérité et
rien que la vérité cela commence mal
après s'être déclarée totalement
innocent à une bonne question de
l'accusation
la version chance à l'été 82 avez-vous
pris conscience que ces pilules que vous
preniez tel était heureusement oui
saviez-vous qu'en prenant six
terroristes totalement interdite vous
pouviez par des tests vous faire exclure
par exemple des jeux olympiques
oui conclusions avant d'aller plus loin
à l'instigation veine johnson à séoul
était au courant de ce qu'ils prenaient
et qu'il pouvait très bien être démasqué
par un contrôle antidopage
pas mal pour un premier jour de procès à
suivre à suivre aussi les pronostics de
pierre de bresse pour le trc de demain à
chantilly les voici le 2 le 6 le 7 le 14
18 le 16 le 1 et le 12
dans un instant après la pub laurent
cabrol vous parlera du temps de demain
malgré la grève qui continue à la
météorologie nationale que vers 23h30
henri sannier vous présentera notre
dernier journal demain à partir de 6h30
rendez vous avec l'équipe de télématin
et à 7h45 pour les quatre vérités
madame simone veil qui conduit la liste
centriste aux élections européennes
voilà très bonne soirée sur antenne 2
jean marie cavada à demain 20 heures